thank you for joining us i'm john
langler no child should be named
john doe however this afternoon that is
still the case
for a boy found murdered near mountain
springs last friday
today the fbi and metro police tried to
energize the search with
four answers with new sketches of the
victim and a new reward
for information bianca holmen is live at
metro headquarters with those pictures
bianca good afternoon afternoon john
well metro says they've received several
hundred tips from not only here in las
vegas but across the country
but they believe that the boy was either
from nye county or clark county or even
from
the southern part of bordering states
but they also say that the boy's body
was in the mountain springs for less
than a day
now take a look at your screen right now
this is a digitally enhanced photograph
of the boy
and they believe that he was a hispanic
boy roughly around 8 to 10 years old
with black hair and brown eyes
the child is 4 foot 11 and about 123
pounds
metro homicide lieutenant ray spencer
says other agencies are helping with
this case too
ccsd homeland security border patrol and
surrounding police departments
i want them to know that we are doing
absolutely everything
and i'm confident that we are going to
find the person who is responsible
for committing this horrible act and
leaving him
out in mountain springs i can tell you
the resources and the effort that
as a police agency that we are putting
into this again that i'm confident that
we will eventually get
to the suspect
police are calling the boy joe little
zion doe because
of the little zion trail which was near
where he was found
metra also says that if anyone was
traveling on state route 60 between
midnight on late thursday to 7 a.m on
friday morning
who noticed anything unusual unusual
like a car pulled over on the side of
the road or
pulled into an area that stuck out to
give them a call now there is a ten
thousand dollar reward and of course you
can remain anonymous and they are
actually asking you to call
about if you have any tips on who the
suspect might be or can i
identify joe little zion doe to actually
call 1-800
call fbi reporting live bianca holman 8
news
now